if ever we needed proof Corbin and his
mob aren't fit to run a whelk store let
alone a country president Trump's visit
was it this pathetic excuse for a leader
and London's pipsqueak mares that he'd
gone shamed Britain by mocking goading
and insulting the leader of the free
world who whatever you think of him it's
still Britain's greatest ally and the
man who posed brexit could save our
backsides with a bumper trade deal
Corbin childishly refused to attend a
state banquet and then whipped up an
angry lynch mob some of whom called
Trump supporters Nazis while Kant
compared the President to the fascist
leaders of the 30s and 40s who destroyed
Europe thank God for the Queen who
understands state visits are about the
mutual interests of both countries and
treated Trump and his family with
courtesy and grace this visit was
supposed to be about commemorating d-day
honoring the men and women from here and
the u.s. who 75 years ago stood shoulder
to shoulder ready to sacrifice their
lives for our Liberty yet left-wing
politicians were determined to make it
all about them shame I mean I think
there was a parade of virtue signaling
and gesture politics and I think that
for the leader of two main parties lived
em as a main party now Vince Cable and
Jeremy Corbyn along with shadow foreign
secretary
Emily Thornbury to actually join the
demonstrations was I can't really find
words but I mean hey you have to be
quite childish to make President Donald
Trump look this classy you know what in
my mind I you know I I read I've been
reading all the stuff about d-day we've
seen these amazing pictures today and
all the vets out there and then I see
that the face is twisted with hate of
those they treated I mean I think this
Trump supporters in the crowd some of
them were actually attacked a milkshake
again
just give this a rest this was a moment
for dignity and respect as we say on the
pledge as for Emily Thornbury I mean her
line that she wouldn't if she were 30
years younger she wouldn't be in a room
alone with Donald Trump lamenting we
need to hear what Emily Thornbury has
said in justification of her I think
rather unjustifiable stance on this this
is not anti Americanism this is actually
Pro Americanism I'm a great lover of
America i bequeath them and I and I and
I'm a friend of them because of their
values because of their values of
democracy and equality and
internationalism and working with our
friends you know that's and when you
have a close friend who is going the
wrong way who was led by a man like this
who was undermining the very essence of
the great things about America then it
should be called out I just think it
didn't reflect badly on Donald Trump it
dangerous all being in violent agreement
let me just take this a different way
because I think you're mostly right but
not wholly right and let's just reflect
on what Jeremy Corbyn said that defeats
racism defeats misogyny defeats the
religious hatreds that are being fueled
by the far right in politics in Britain
in Europe and the United States now what
was incredibly embarrassing for mr.
Coleman was it subsequently learned that
he had sought but did not gain a meeting
with this is what I would say if labor
politicians or anybody else do not want
to attend a meeting with Donald Trump
they have the right so to do that is the
country in which we live and they can
have their protest what I think is
unprecedented and also for me
unforgivable is you have someone who if
election was to go this way he would
actually be the leader of the country
and he's attending a rally and speaking
in that way and I think it is
unpardonable because it is the queen is
the monarch who invited Jeremy Corbyn
and then Emily
we to the banquet so by not going by not
you're actually snubbing the monitor
you're snubbing the queen you're not sir
and this is a man just fine a card this
is a man who apparently can't sit down
with Donald Trump but we know can sit
down with the IRA Hezbollah Hamas and
has a trouble winter mooner comes into
the room go figure
and you know what he just said they was
talking about the values or values of
peace values and you know and he's
talking about racism misogyny he need to
look to his own party I think again in
danger of all of us being in violent
agreement I need to just put out the
case from a perspective that I think the
people protesting at least not only had
a right to but genuinely yes that's
right so official to the polit the
citizens protesting had some genuine
causes that they care about environment
and so on and so forth I do think
holders of the Office of State shouldn't
act like student union presidents and
boycotts especially when it's an
official state invitation are hosted by
our queen boycott these banquets
especially when they're prepared to meet
President Xi of China in such cases I
would however and just again for balance
I would say that the mayor of London who
is another whole room office of
government and he's spat with President
Trump in that spat that's ongoing now
online for a while you can see that both
sides are being a bit puerile and
childish and comments started out so
calm I think actually that's part of the
puerile response who started it Carolyn
I just wanna respond to your
introduction because he called him a
pipsqueak in your introduction and
that's the kind of language Trump uses
as well that can of course with the
blimp it's not become childish he's not
a pipsqueak and he's not a buffoon let's
try and repair a democratically elected
president to the because that's a really
know but that was a reasoned debate in
the observer he wrote a piece and it
used
grown-up language who did man I'm not a
fan of his but I support it because it
was I don't agree with it but it was a
reasoned and rational and that was
responded to by Trump going up from
because of his height we don't play that
I think we've been hearing organs by
hate about divisive talking about hate
when you compare a democratically
elected president to those leaders in
the 30s and for
who destroyed Europe and who who
murdered lots of people it's farcical
and what all Trump did yes Trump's
comments were pure right but you know
what he said was largely true he said he
was short not a very good mayor and a
stone-cold there's one thing missing at
the moment it's just professionalism
simple professionalism and I find what's
going on in politics just I found it
embarrassing and I want politicians to
be better there's not me and my mayor
arguing in a pot over something these
are professional people that have been
appointed to represent and it doesn't
matter whether you like someone dislike
somebody that should be irrelevant you
should be able to disagree
professionally and to your point about
the protesters that we saw I thought
that was absolutely or whose every point
it was when I was watching people
we're throwing around insults like Nazi
because I because I disagree with you
you are nasty just we all need to calm
down be professional and just behave as
President Trump was used to be insulted
he's used to protest what happened in
this country over the past three or four
days would play well for him because all
the state and the pomp in the circle
keep in mind something will not play
well is what we have on the boycott
thing we may well have another prime
minister very soon in the yeah and you
know how would we feel if because he's
also similarly by certain quarters
viewed in certain ways and if he visited
another country we would want him to be
respected as the prime minister of this
country how would we feel if other
countries that started saying those who
are a bit more left-wing than us of this
guy made certain comments about letter
boxes and face veils and therefore we're
just going to boycott that state visit
and that was actually Jeremy Corbyn
Rachel Corbin is only doing what we know
Corbin has done isn't that right there's
what we seen with the bond in that
speech is what we've always seen from
him it's the idea that he had addressed
the rally that's so upsetting to you the
fact that he was there and I think that
there is a tradition which dates back
from you know ancient Greece where a
guest you if you are again
and you arrive in somebody's home or in
their country you give them a you know
you are generous you are courteous you
give them your dad was old I didn't use
around the dead Greeks Corbin's done
what he's always done but he's now
aspiring to be the leader of this
country so he can't do what is always
done he's got to be a leader now